In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
Dear Jesus, may I enter into the eternal divine order of God to place my absolute nothingness
in the heart of the most holy Trinity, to give to my God the joy of fulfilling the purpose of
my existence by doing all the acts of my life through the immaculate heart of my mother Mary
and in the divine will of God. And in this same manner, may I live, pray, act, eat, walk, sleep,
and do everything. May my soul be devoid of any other longings, wants, or desires, and may you,
my beloved divine, will do with me whatever you want or desire. All I ask is that you bind me
to your most holy will so intimately that I may never swear from carrying out what I know to be
your good pleasure and that I remain so docile to the movements of your divine will that you never
perceive even a breath of resistance in my soul to your requests of me. Come divine will with all
the angels and saints, especially my sweet mother Mary, to touch my forehead, to imprint on it the
Holy Spirit and infuse in me true light, so that I may understand the truths and the good that are
in these writings and prayers. Amen. So this evening we're going to have a lot on fusing and the
rounds of creation, redemption, and sanctification. So it's more a prayer than a class really.
So let's begin on May the 10th 1925 and Louisa is asked to explain the different things that
happened to her when she fuses and this might create a few questions among people. I mean what
do we do when we fuse? Okay, won't answer that now. I've asked the question as I have a right to
ask a question, you know. So Louisa said I write only out of obedience and I will make a mix of
past things and present things to try and answer the question. Many times in my writings I say I
was fusing myself in the divine volition and I don't explain further. Now forced by obedience
I will say what happens to me infusing myself. Now she's going to take, she's going to take
seven things and this is the first one. As I fuse myself and immense void all of light,
now this is the divine will and God is light, one Timothy 616, he dwells in unapproachable light.
So an immense void all of light becomes present before my mind. Now she's allowed to experience
this, we have to do it by faith. Such that one could neither find the extent of its height nor
if its depth nor of its boundaries on the right or on the left or those in the front and the back.
So she's talking about the infinite immensity of the divine will. In the midst of this immensity
at a point extremely high. So if you are with me for the book of Revelation and we've already done
chapters four and five then the extremely high point is the throne of God. I seem to see the
divinity she said or the three divine persons waiting for me but she said this always happens
mentally. That's interesting because we were used to Louisa actually going out of the body
and experiencing this sort of quasi physically as it seems when she's describing it but she says
she's doing this in our mind. It's very interesting to know what you do in your mind when you're
fusing. So she said this is always mentally and I don't know how a little girl comes out of me
but it is my own self maybe it's my little soul. You see our being is just like a child in God's
presence so she sees herself as a little girl but it is moving to see this little girl she said
placing herself on the way in this immense empty space. Now we're going to have to find out why it's
empty and the girl is all alone shy walking on tiptoe with her eyes always fixed on the place
where she sees the three divine persons because she fears that if she lowers her gaze in that
immense void she wouldn't know at which point she would end up. In other words she could get
completely lost. Now the first thing I want to give you is the song of songs chapter eight verse
five. Who is this coming up out of the desert having the incredible courage to go and face God
on his own throne the admiration of all heaven. The second thing is what is contemplation? Contemplation
is I look at him and he looks at me. So you see Louisa contemplating the blessed Trinity and at the
height of their throne in glory and she sees herself as somebody tiny but that doesn't put her off
not at all and something very very interesting happens here and she said all the strength of this
little girl is in that gaze fixed on high. In fact as her gaze is responded to by the gaze of the
supreme height. Now that's Louisa's way of saying God in his supreme majesty or what the bible would
call Elion God most high. In fact as her gaze is responded to by the gaze of the God most high
she draws strength along the way and as she arrives before them God them one in three
she plunges herself with her face into that void to adore the divine majesty. This is exactly what
you find in Revelation 4 and 5 that those who are around the throne of God and therefore can see
God in his majesty and greatness and glory that they have no objection at all to plunging themselves
on their faces in adoration and praise because they see what we can't see and understand what we
can't understand. So here she is in adoration before the Trinity. Now that's the very first
action that we must take going into the presence of God that we're only creatures. We're coming
before the divinity and we go into adoration. Now the next thing fascinates me completely.
She said but one hand from the three persons raises the little girl. Now that one hand has to be
Jesus because he is the Redeemer. So just think of her before the essence of God and here she is
this tiny little creature coming from planet earth and all its filth and sinfulness and failure and
all the rest of it and she dares to come close what how close can you come and then one hand
from the three divine persons reaches out to her and says to her our daughter the little
daughter of our will come into our arms. Now you mightn't realize that behind that is a
gesture that goes right back into antiquity and that is when you go into the Bible you find that
King Solomon for example had a kind of sea of glass before his throne that nobody could cross
unless he reached out to them. You remember the book of Esther and the Jewish queen Esther
wanting to approach the pagan Gentile King Ashueras and she broke all protocols by entering the hall
without permission and if he had simply given the thumbs down they would have killed her it was
as simple as that but I think he was so fascinated watching her come forward and this is what you're
reading here and then he reaches out his mace to her and when he reaches out the mace to her
everybody knows she's accepted and she may come forward she may reach the intimacy she's looking
for and this is what is being described here. Now who would have thought that that event which
happened centuries before Christ would be repeated with Louisa in the 20th century? In heaven it's
amazing to me and as I say fascinates me but you know from the Bible and you know from the book of
Exodus that nobody can come into the presence of God without being called and you go back to Exodus
chapter 3 and if Moses is at the burning bush he has to stay back until he's called forward.
When they arrive at Sinai after all the plagues of Egypt and the escape out of Egypt they cannot
go forward to the holy mountain unless God calls and God specifically tells Moses who may come
and who may not come and if you're not on that list you can't go it's as simple as that.
So now Louisa is given the invitation to come forward into the inner courts of the Lord.
So on hearing this this little girl becomes festive and makes the three divine persons
festive as they await the carrying out of her office entrusted to her by them so we're going
to see what her office is and with grace typical of a little girl she said I come to adore you
to bless you to thank you for everyone. I'm not coming just for myself that kind of intimacy
would not be given to someone on earth just for their own satisfaction or sanctification.
I come to bind to your throne all the human wills of all generations that is the office
given to her to try and connect the human will with the divine will and to open the era of the
divine will on the earth. So I come to bind to your throne the human wills of all generations
from the first to the last man I always say Adam to Zachary A to Z so that everyone may recognize
your supreme will they may adore it love it and give it life within their souls. So this is what
you'll meet in the New Jerusalem at the end of the book of Revelation when the divine will is on
the earth and God is in the midst of his people. So she says supreme majesty in this immense void
look at this all the creatures are there. Now first of all she tells you it's an immense void
that was a void means an emptiness and then she says all the creatures are there so what's missing
if we're all there and it's still a void what's missing is the human will. The human will has
been taken out of God's will and that human will has got to come back to fill that void
and to do all that God asks. So this immense void full of creatures but still empty means that the
human creatures have not surrendered their will to the divine will. So she said and I want to take
them all in order to place them in your will in other words to fill the void and so that's one of
the tasks that we have in the mission of the divine will to fill that void so that everyone
may return to the origin from which they came that is your will. Now one of the things I absolutely
love about that is that in the world people think they've made immense progress because after all
we can we've managed to go to another planet and we've sent all these rockets we've got people
trying to live in space for longer and longer and we've got all this machinery and we've got all
this modern communications and blah blah blah. But we haven't made any progress because the
Lord says you have to go back to your origin to start. So the only progress we can make is to go
backwards and then we've got to go right back to the origin where Adam left off and pick up there
and the human race has then got to make progress in the divine will because any progress outside
of the divine will is a puff of wind of no value. And so our poor scientists and all these people
who think they're awfully clever and they brought us up to this extraordinary thing where we now
have you know artificial intelligence and we're going to have robots who can fight battles and
all the rest of it. They think they've made progress. And Louise it realizes that unless she could
take the human race back to its origin and pick up from where we left off we haven't got anywhere.
So she says to the most blessed Trinity this is why I have come into your paternal arms
to bring you all your children and they are brothers and sisters of mine and to bind them
all to your will so that we can all start again. And in the name of all and for everyone I want to
repair you and to give you the homage and the glory as if all had done your most holy will.
So now the mission is you come into the presence of the three most divine persons of the Trinity
and we go into adoration and praise and then we tell the Lord we want to bind all human
wills to his will. We want to collect them all and bring them all into his presence.
We want to make reparation and substitution furthermore.
And we want to give God the homage and the glory that all should have given to him.
But oh please she said I pray you let there be no more separation between the divine
and the human will because we're told over and over again that the divine will and the human will
do not mix. But who can say everything she said it would be too long or while I was distracted
there it said I know that you don't deny anything to little ones we heard little ones there.
Matthew 18 5 so in addition to the fact that I lack the words to express what I say before the
supreme height God's infinite majesty it seems to me that here in the low world back on earth
where we're making progress in the wrong direction we do not use the same languages in that immense
void and that's terribly important. If you go to John chapter 8 and verse 43 you'll hear Jesus
saying to the scribes and Pharisees the problem is that you can't even hear my language we're not
even speaking the same language and so the language of heaven and the language of the low world is
very very different. Those of us trying to live in the divine will know that what is perfectly
ordinary for us to talk about if you went out and tried to say that out on the main street of your
town they were probably sent for the men in the white coat they wouldn't have any idea what you
were saying. So this is the very first thing that Louisa does when she goes into the presence
of God. Now the second thing she does is she puts her I love you on everything so that she does it
for everyone so and she comes back to the supreme majesty and she says now look at your creation
and look at everything you've done there's an I love you on everything I call that putting your
own stamp on it. There's a Louisa I love you on everything there should be a Francis I love you
on everything there should be an emulator I love you on everything and so on and so forth. I think
when he gets enough signatures he he'll say ah yeah okay they want me back. Other times Louisa said
while I fuse myself in the divine volition and that immense void comes before my mind I go around
through all created things and I impress on them. You see impress on them to me is a stamp. You
actually press something on to it. I press and I love you for the supreme majesty as though wanting
to fill the whole atmosphere with many I love yous in order to requite the supreme love for so much
love towards creatures. Now the first thing is she puts her I love you on absolutely everything.
Now where is she going? Even more she said I go around through each thought of the creature she's
talking about human beings here I hate that word creature because the word creature actually
includes animals. I go around through each thought of every human being and I impress on them
my I love you and through each gaze and I leave my I love you within them and through each mouth
and each word and I seal them with the I love you. I go through each heartbeat each work each step
and I cover them with my I love you to my god. I go deep down into the sea she suddenly jumps
as Louisa loves going all over the place with things like a butterfly. I go deep down into the
sea into the depths of the ocean and I want to fill each darting of the fish every drop of water
with my I love you and then after she has sowed her I love you everywhere the little girl brings
yourself before the divine majesty she keeps on going back and as though wanting to give him a
surprise as only a little child would do you know plucking your best rose from the front garden and
bringing it in and offering it to you and saying I love you you know. So wanting to give him a
surprise she says my creator and my father my Jesus and my eternal love is not a lovely way
to address the blessed Trinity. Luke all things on the part of all creatures tell you that they love
you now it's her I love you that's on everything and so what they see is a Louisa stamp on everything
but because God is love to put a stamp of love on something means that he recognizes his own work.
All things on the part of creatures tell you that they love you everywhere there's an I love
you for you heaven and earth are filled with them and you will you not concede to your tiny little
one that you your will descend into the midst of creatures and make itself known and make peace
with the human will. So you see the ultimate thing is to bring that union between the human will
and the divine will because there's going to be no restoration as long as the human will is in rebellion
to the divine will and so we have to keep coming back to this point of asking God to combine those
two wills and as the divine will takes its just dominion its place of honor no creature may ever
do their own will again you see the point we were trying to talk about last night and that is we
have to reach the point where we handed over finally. So in the next paragraph she moves on
to another exercise it's very interesting to just make a list of the exercises she's actually doing
here. Other times she said when I fuse myself in the divine volition I want to feel sorrow for
all the offenses given to my God and I resume my round within that immense void of the divine will
in order to find all the sorrow that Jesus felt for all sins that would have been an infinite sorrow.
I made it my own and I go around everywhere in the most hidden and secret places in public places
where all the evil human acts are done to feel sorrow for all the offenses and for each sin.
I feel I would want to cry out at each motion of the creatures sorrow forgiveness
and so that all may hear it I am pressed on the rumbling of the thunder very good sign isn't it?
Because the thunder in the scriptures is always the sign that God is trying to get through to us.
So that sorrow for having offended my God made thunder in all hearts and that means that they
will actually hear it because if a clap of thunder goes right over your house there's no way you
won't hear it. She said I cry for forgiveness in the striking of the lightning I cry sorrow
in the whistling of the wind sorrow and forgiveness in the tinkling of the bells in some sorrow and
forgiveness in everything and then I bring to my God the sorrow of all and I implore forgiveness
for all and I say great God let your will descend upon the earth so that sin may take its place no
more. It is the human will alone that produces so many offenses as to seem to be flooding the
earth with sins your will will be the destroyer of all evils. You see you cannot even attempt to live
in the divine will if there is sin in your soul. Sin has to be absolutely banished to live in the
divine will and when we come to the point of sacrificing that will forever as we looked at
last night with that big X then the divine will actually destroy all evils in the human will because
the human will is then submitted but I want to give you a revelation 1118 where God says I will
destroy the destroyers of the earth. Therefore, Louisa says I pray you make the little doffer of
your will content. She wants nothing else but that your will be known and loved and that it
reign in all hearts. That's number three. Now number four is that she's in her bed looks out the window
it's raining and so she shows you how to respond to simply a weather sign. I think it's beautiful.
I remember that one day I was using myself in the holy divine volition and I was looking at the sky
and it was pouring with rain. I felt great pleasure in seeing water pouring down over the earth and
my sweet Jesus moving in my interior with unspeakable love and tenderness told me my doffer in those
drops of water which you see descending from the heavens there is my will. My will runs rapidly
together with the water. It departs in order to quench the thirst of the creatures to descend
into the human bowels and their veins in order to refresh them and to constitute itself the life
of the creatures and to bring them my kiss and my love. It departs in order to water the earth
to fecundate it and to prepare the food for them. It departs for many other needs of creatures. My
will wants to have life in all created things in order to give celestial and natural life to all
creatures. There's something absolutely beautiful there and he's saying that in every drop of water
that comes to us he's coming and as the water gives us life he is giving us his life and if we
would receive his life with the water it would help enormously. He said my will wants to have
life in all created things so we don't have a concept that reign is the divine will descending
from heaven to the earth. However while the divine will goes towards all as though in feast and full
of love it does not receive an adequate response of love and gratitude and reparation and substitution
and all the rest that Louisa is doing in her fusing. And it remains as though on an empty stomach on
the part of creatures in other words he identifies us throughout these writings as the ungrateful ones.
My daughter, your will also fused in mine runs within that water. Now fused means
calm union. The human will, the divine will, they become one. So if you become one and the divine
will is coming down in the rain then your will is coming down in the rain as well. If the divine
will is coming down in the sunshine then your will is coming down in the sunshine. That's absolutely
incredible. So you become part of giving life to the whole earth. You enter into the very essence
of things is fascinating. So my daughter, your will also fused in mine runs within that water and
rains down from the heavens. It runs together with it wherever the divine will goes. So never leave
the divine will alone. Stay in contact and give it the requital of your love and do it for everybody.
So the more often we tell him, I love you with your will on behalf of all the better.
But as he was saying this, she said, Louisa said, my pupils remained enchanted. I could not move
from that pouring water, she said. My will was running with it. And in that water I could see
the hands of my Jesus multiplied into many in order to bring water to everyone with his own hands.
So she sees everything graphically so that she can say it in a very physical way to us.
If she said it in a very intellectual way, we mightn't get it. But who can say what I felt
within me? She said, only Jesus can say it. He who is the author of it. And who can say the many
ways of fusing myself in the most holy volition? In other words, she's saying, look, there are
many ways of doing this and I'm not going to tell you them all. And she's very good at not telling
you them all. And at the end of this long dissertation, she's going to say, I had to skip a whole lot.
So the next one is extremely important. So we're on to number five now. And that is when we come
into the presence of God, we've got to fill that void on behalf of everyone, because the void is
God's will. In addition to this, she said, I was saying to my Jesus, tell me my love,
what is this void that makes itself present before my mind when I fuse myself in your holy will?
And who is the little girl that comes out of me? And why does she feel an irresistible force,
which of course is the divine will, to come to your throne in order to place her little acts
on the divine lap, almost to make a feast for him? And my sweet Jesus, all goodness told me,
my daughter, the void is my will. And it is placed at your disposal. That's the fascinating thing,
which should be filled with so many acts for as many as the creatures would have done
had they fulfilled my will. So that's why it's a void because all of these acts have not been done
by people who are living with rebellious wills. This immense void that you see, which represents
our will, came out from our divinity for the good of all of creation in order to make everyone
and everything happy. I think that's a very interesting thing. I understand making everyone
happy. What about making everything happy? You know, because there's a statement in one of
the Psalms that the trees of the field clap their hands for joy. Okay. Therefore, as a result,
all creatures should have filled this void with the requital of their acts and with the offering
of their wills to their creator. Ooh, ooh, notice that. Not only with their acts, now we're all
good at doing the acts. We won't leave that out. Okay. But also with the offering of their wills,
you see, this is the essence of the thing that we are to be laying down our will before the divine
will. And we have got to learn that to do that every nanosecond of our lives so that in the end,
he says, okay, I take it and he confirms the gift. But since they do not do so giving us the greatest
offense, we called you with a special mission to be compensated for and requited for all that
the others owe us. So notice there's the compensation and the substitution for all the others.
And this is the reason why first we disposed you with a long chain of graces. See, this is very
interesting. All of us are on this journey and the Lord is disposing us all the time with this
long chain of graces. And at the right moment, we're able to lay down our will fully and completely.
So we disposed you with a long chain of graces. And then we asked you if you wanted to live in
the divine will. So this is the laying down of the will. And you said, yes, that's fiat binding your
will to our throne. That's core ban. You bound your will to our throne. And once you do something as
serious as that there is no going back, none whatsoever. And it tells her many times you can try to go
back at this point you can't because you're bound to an eternal will. And once you are bound to
something eternal, the change that can go on in the low earth is not going to happen. So you said,
yes, binding your will to our throne, wanting to know it never again, because the human will and
the divine will do not mix. They do not combine. We have lots of things in the chemical world
that don't mix and they don't combine. They cannot live together. So whatever bits of me have not
been handed over to the divine will, he can't do anything with that. He's got to wait for me to
hand over. Now that yes, that is your will exists bound tightly to our throne. Notice the bound
tightly to our throne. And this is why your soul like a little girl is drawn before the Supreme
Majesty, because that's where your will is. Your will is up there bound to that throne,
and that's why you're drawn towards it. So we may wonder why we don't have the same level of drawing
as she has. It's because you may not have bound your will to that throne and left it there and walked
off. That's where your will is. And it is your will that draws you like a magnet. And you instead
of looking at your will occupy yourself only in bringing into our lap everything that you have
been able to do in our will. So you don't bring just human nothings therefore to the throne of God,
you are bringing divine acts to him. And you place our very will in our bosom as the greatest homage
which be fits us and the requital that is most pleasing to us. Your heedlessness of your own will
and our will which alone lives in you makes us festive. So now we know what makes God happy.
When we have finally handed over the human will to the divine. Your little acts done in our will
bring us the joys of the whole of creation. So here's one little soul doing what she can
and God takes it as a gift from the whole out of us. Isn't it amazing? So it seems that everything
smiles at us and makes feasts for us because she has stamped everything with her. I love you.
She has said sorry for everybody. She's asked forgiveness for everybody. She's done everything
she can to bind the human will to the divine will and to come back to God and say look I'm doing
my little bit. So it seems that everything smiles he said and seeing that you descend from our throne
without even looking at your will. Now we'll go into this just to remind you of it that anything
you read about our blessed mother in the divine will that she absolutely handed over her will in
the first instance of conception which is beyond my mind to actually grasp and she says herself
that she never ever ever looked at her own will. The heroism of that is beyond my ability to even
think about it. So he says that without even looking at your will carrying our will with you
is the greatest joy for us. In other words here's a creature acting the exact way that the creator
actually wants. So this is why I always say to you be attentive to our will because only in our will
there is much to do because in it there's much to do and the more you do the greater the feast
you will make for us and our volition will pour out in torrents inside and outside of you.
The impression you get of God if you read the Old Testament superficially is that he is a
thundering angry God. If you read the Old Testament with any level of insight or understanding you'll
start feeling very sorry for him and I call him a big softie and the reason why I call him a big
softie is that if you make the slightest effort at repentance even if you don't succeed fully
oh he changes completely. He can't get over the fact that you're making an effort. So we can't
imagine the joy we're giving to God in all of us trying to actually walk this journey towards the
death of self and the death of our will to give him complete glory while we are alive. I don't think
we could imagine it. So on May the 17th 1925 we're going on with more fusing and here we're going
to go into the rounds of creation redemption and sanctification and even when she's finished all
of this she'll say no I took some jumps. Louisa said after I let the confessor hear of what was
written in the part we've just read he wasn't satisfied and he imposed another obedience on her.
Okay so in the first paragraph now we're going to have the rounds of creation. Now I add she said
this is the sixth area she's dealing with. I add that in that immense void as the immense
void becomes present before my mind when I fuse myself into supreme volition the little girl continues
her round and rising up high she wants to requite her God for all the love that he had for creatures
in creation. So for everything that he has done in love she wants to try and give him back and I
love you to cover that. She wants to honor him as the creator of all things and so she goes round
through the stars and in each twinkling of light she impresses my I love you and glory to my creator
in each atom of the light of the sun she that descends down below I love you and glory to my creator
and in the whole expanse of the heavens within the distance from one step to another I love you and
glory. Now she's going to make a terrible jump now to talk about birds because in the last sentence
she's been talking about deep space and the galacties and everything and then she makes this
enormous jump which doesn't make any sense to me because you'd expect her to go on talking
about the the glories of creation. So in the warbling of the bird in the beating of its wings love and
glory to my creator in the blade of grass which sprouts from the earth in the flower that blooms
in the fragrance that ascends love and glory to my creator. On the height of the mountains in the
depths of the valleys love and glory now what I see here you may not agree and it doesn't matter
to me whether you do or not what I see here is that she hasn't got the patience to tell us the
whole thing she hasn't she hasn't got the patience to go through all the detail of what she's actually
doing so she just jumps around from here and there. I go around she said through each heart now we're
dealing with human beings and as though wanting to enclose myself in it to cry out from inside each
heart now the only way you can cry out from inside each heart is that you fuse yourself in the divine
will and there you find those creatures and therefore you can cry out from their hearts now there's
the way for you to intercede for all your loved ones that you're worried about and you don't worry
about them you fuse yourself in the divine will and in the divine will you find your loved ones and
you can put shafts of light into their intellect memory and will and you can put flames of love
into their hearts and you can get inside of their hearts and from their hearts give God all the
prayers that they should be praying the most wonderful thing you can do but don't worry about
it so in the name of all the people she wants to intercede for she gives my I love you and glory
to my creation I would want that there would only be one cry one will and one harmony in everything
there's only one divine will and that everything in harmony would say glory and love to my creator
and then as though having gathered everything together in such a way that everything says
required love love and attestation of glory for all that God has done in creation I bring myself
to his throne so we're going back again so you do all this work on the earth and then you go back
to God's throne and offer him what you've done so I said to you a moment ago this is how you can
pray for all your loved ones that you're worried about and when you do all that work then you come
back and say you go back to the throne of God and you say Lord I bring you all my loved ones and all
of this that we've done for them it's absolutely amazing I bring myself to his throne I say to him
supreme majesty and creator of all things this little girl comes into your arms to tell you
that all creation and in the name of all creatures that she gives you the requital not only of love
but of just glory for the many things created by you for love of us in your will in this immense
void I have wandered everywhere so that all things may glorify you love you and bless you and now
that I have placed for you the love between the creator and the creature in their relationship
which the human will has broken as well as the glory that everyone owed you that your will
descend upon the earth now what she's saying is I've entered into all of these creatures I have
given you the requital of love and glory and sorrow and forgiveness and absolutely everything
that they all should do for you now I'm bringing them all back to you to cement the relationship
between you and them again because of this I want you to let your will come to the earth it's really
wonderful so let your will descend upon the earth that it may bind and strengthen all the relations
between the creator and the creature all things will return to the original order established by you
therefore hurry delay no more don't you see that the earth is full of evils and your will alone
can stop the evils now look at that statement it's absolutely incredible and you'll see that
why the Lord is bringing as many as possible into his divine will I ask him as often as possible
bring as many as possible into your divine will because that's the only way that your will
for the earth will be done it's the only way that your plan for the human race will be accomplished
is to get as many as possible into the divine will because as the numbers trying to live the
divine will increase you will eventually get to what is called the critical mass
and then the kingdom of Satan is absolutely pushed aside and destroyed so your will alone can stop
this current I can place it in safety but your will known understood and ruling she said that means
that we've all surrendered to the divine will so now in the next paragraph we go back from the
throne of God and we now do the rounds of redemption so the rounds of creation was the first fiat
and now we're going to the second one then after this I feel that my office is not complete
and therefore I descend to a lower level within the void so at the absolute height of the void you
got the throne of God and at the lower level she does her work in the divine will in order to
requite Jesus for the work of redemption and as though finding all that he did in act I want to
give him my requital of all the acts which all creatures should have done for him in awaiting him
and receiving him upon the earth and then as though wanting to transform all into myself for love
of Jesus I go back in my refrain I love you in your act of descending from heaven I just go to go
through every as much detail of Jesus's life as she has the patience to write down because she
likes jumping you see so she has put the stamp of her I love you on all of creation on the heavenly
spheres and everything that's on the earth and now she puts her stamp of love on everything in
redemption and this is very very important it's our participation in the mystery and so Jesus needs
to have our signature I call the rounds our signature he needs our signature on everything that we have
entered into what he has done in creation we've entered into what he's done in redemption we've
entered into what he's done in sanctification and we've said yes with him and we have tried to give
him the response that the human race should have given him so she says I love you in your act of
descending from heaven in the incarnation I impress my I love you on your act of being conceived I love
you in the first drop of blood which was formed in your humanity I love you in the first beat of
your heart so as to mark all of your heart beats with my I love you I love you in your first breath
I love you in your first pains I love you in the first tears you shed in your the maternal womb
I want to requite your prayers your reparations your offerings with my I love you I want to seal
each instant of your life with my I love you I love you in your being born I love you in the
cold you suffered I love you in each drop of the milk you suckled from your mother I intend to
fill with my I love you the clothes which your mother swaddled you I lay my I love you upon the
ground on which your dear mother laid you down gently in the manger and your most tender limbs
felt the hardness of the hay but more than the hay you felt the hardness of hearts my I love you
in each of your wailings in all the tears and pains of your tender age I make my I love you flow
within all the relations and communications and love between you and your mother I love you in
each word you spoke the food you took the steps you took and the water you drank I love you in the
work you did with your hands I love you in all the acts you did during your hidden life I seal my I
love you in each one of your interior acts and in the pains you suffered I lay my I love you on the
roads you covered in the air you breathed in the sermons you gave during your public life
my I love you flows in the power of the miracles you performed and the sacraments you instituted
in everything oh my Jesus even in the most innermost fibers of your heart I impress my I love you for
myself and for everybody that's extremely important and for everybody in this mission of the divine
will we're not there for our own sanctification we're there to serve God for everyone your will
makes everything present to me and I don't want to leave anything out in which my I love you is not
impressed your little daughter daughter of your will feels the duty if there is nothing else you
can do for you that you may have at least a little I love you for everything you have done for me
and for everyone therefore my I love you follows you in all the pains of your passion in all the
spit scorns insults that they gave you my I love you seals each drop of the blood you shed each
blow that you received each wound that formed in your body each thorn that pierced your head
the bitter pains of the crucifixion the words you pronounced on the cross up to your last breath
I intend to impress my I love you I want to close all of your life all of your acts with my I love you
I want you to touch see and feel my continuous I love you everywhere so it's not just given once
it's given continuously my I love you will never leave you your own very will is the life of my
I love you because everything is done in the divine will and of course it's multiplied to infinity
it's absolutely amazing but you know this little girl wants because you would say after all that
is there something you actually want that the divine volition which you so much loved and
which you did during your whole life upon the earth would make itself known to all
so if this is the only thing she wants then you see that her prayer is extraordinarily pure
she's looking for nothing for herself she's looking for no advantage she's looking for no grace
she's looking for nothing she only wants purely what God wants and that's extraordinary
that your will make itself known to all creatures so that all may love the divine will
and may fulfill your will on earth as it is in heaven this little girl wants to conquer you in love
now that's a very beautiful thing and you often hear that among the other saints as well
that since God is love the only way you can conquer his heart is through love
I want to this little girl wants to conquer you in love that you may give your will to all creatures
or please make this poor little one happy who wants nothing else you see the purity of intention here
and the purity of her love and the purity of her prayer purity means nothing else is mixed with it
she wants nothing else but what you want that your will be known and that it reign upon the earth
then she says now I believe that her obedience will be content in some way although it's true that in
many things I've had to make a few jumps there's her confession you see she jumps all over the place
she's otherwise I'd never end fusing myself in the supreme position is like a springing
found for me and every little thing I hear or see one offense given to my Jesus is an occasion for
me for new ways and new fusions in his most holy will so now in the next paragraph we begin
the third fiat the rounds of sanctification now I continue to say what my sweet Jesus told me
my daughter to what you have said on fusing yourself in my will another appeal must be added
now I love this because she's just confessed that she makes certain jumps and she had no intention
of going any further so Jesus said you've got to put in the work of the Holy Spirit you've spoken
about God the Father in creation and you've spoken about God the Son in redemption you can't leave
out God the Holy Spirit I just love this relationship between them I think it's marvelous
so you've you've to add another appeal that of fusing yourself in the order of grace in everything
that the sanctifier the Holy Spirit has done and will do for those who are to be sanctified
more so since while we the three divine persons are always united in operating if the creation
points to the Father redemption to the Son the fiat valonta's tour will point to the Holy Spirit
that's a very interesting thing because what we're expecting what the Scripture tells us to expect
from the Holy Spirit is the definitive descent of the Holy Spirit upon the Church and the world
that is the Prophet Joel chapter three verses one to five and you see this in the book of Revelation
as the new Jerusalem when God is living among us and so things that are said in different ways
in the Scriptures are all coming together he said you do it when on coming before the supreme
majesty you say I come to requite you in love for everything that the sanctifier does on those who
are to be sanctified I come to enter into the order of grace so as to be able to give you the glory
and the requite love love as if all had made themselves saints and to repair you for all the
oppositions for all the lack of response to grace and as much as you can you search within our will
for the acts of grace of the Spirit sanctifier so as to make his sorrow your own as well as his
secret bones his anguishing size in the depths of hearts and seeing himself so unwelcome so I want
to give you Ephesians 4.30 for that where St. Paul says that we should not grieve the Holy Spirit
and since the first act that the Holy Spirit does is to bring our will as the complete
act of their sanctification in seeing himself rejected he moans with inexpressible moans
now Paul speaks about that in Romans 8 I think it's 26 that the Holy Spirit even groans within us
according to the mind of God but if you look at the effect on the apostles when the Holy Spirit
descended on Pentecost you'll realize the extraordinary transformation that's going to come
when the Holy Spirit descends upon the Church and the world in the future
and Jesus said and you in your childlike simplicity should say to him Spirit sanctifier
hurry I implore you I pray you again make your will known to all so that by knowing it
they may love it and welcome your first act of their complete sanctification which is your holy
will my daughter we the three divine persons are inseparable but distinct and in this way
do we want to manifest to the human generations our works for them that while being united among
ourselves each one of us wants to manifest individually that's lovely they three divine persons wants us
to know each one of them individually and not just one of them so the message that follows from this
is just perfect so if you're living in the divine will and you're operating at this level
and you're able to visit the throne of God and you're able to bring the human race to God
what kind of citizenship do you have your citizenship is in heaven and you'll find this
very well illustrated in the letter to the Hebrews chapter 11
their citizenship they belonged to a different kingdom and so they were like strangers and foreigners
and exiles upon the earth okay so Louisa said I was thinking to myself and almost lamenting to
my beloved Jesus that sometimes he allows that he comes and makes me suffer in the presence of
the confessor now this little bit is very illuminating because we're in volume 17 and if you remember
the early volumes from one to ten you will have heard this conversation over and over and over
again but this time Jesus is going to say stop we're not going to have this conversation again
and he's going to explain why so Jesus sometimes comes unless you suffer in the presence of the
confessor she doesn't want that and as much as I try to resist falling into that state of loss of
consciousness which of course is ecstasy and of pain it's impossible for me of course it's
impossible for her because the whole the divine will is not only living but dominating in her so
I say to Jesus my love there was last night you know and there was time for it today you could
have come and made me suffer you know at a more convenient time do you mind for now since the
confessor is here leave me free and later on do whatever you want and I will be at your disposal
now that's where she was in volumes one to ten and it shows you that we can slip back to an earlier
way of thinking in the blink of an eye we don't even we don't even realize we're doing it
but no she said I said this in vain an irresistible force which is the divine will
ruling and dominating in her because she has laid down her will on the altar of God Corwin
and it's no longer exists for her in this ruling sense a irresistible force the divine will
surprises me puts me in a state as if I were dying and so I was lamenting to Jesus about this and
I prayed him not to allow it and he all goodness told me my daughter if I allow it it's because of
the firmness of the confessor you're not the only one involved the church is involved he has
insisted on the church being involved from the very beginning because while this is a private
revelation made to Louisa he is making it officially to the church from the very beginning and he
has insisted on the church participating all the time if I allow it he said it's because of the
firmness of the confessor who does not cease to pray me to make you suffer now there's the
confessor taking a very strong part in Louisa's life and asking the lord I mean he's looking at
what's going on in the world and here is a victim soul that he is supposed to be guiding and he's
saying to the lord look let her suffer and the lord answers the prayer of church coming through
the priest and he always asks Jesus said for the purpose of my glory and implicating me so he's being
an active participant in this mission that's been given to Louisa if I did not concur he said I
would remain dishonored in you and you would cause the truths which I have manifested to you both in
my will and in the other virtues to be put in doubt so if I don't respond to the request of the church
then the priest can go back to the bishop and say listen there's something funny going on here
when I ask god to let her operate as a victim soul nothing happens she mightn't be all that
authentic and so Jesus has to take care that the message that the church gets is actually right
one could say where is the obedience of the victim whose very nature must be transformed
into what obedience wants look at that whose very nature must be transformed most people think
that obedience is simply that if I ask you to carry that cop to the table that it's the material
thing of carrying the cop to the table not the surrender of my will to do something and obedience
for Louisa is always the interior thing always and he says you must be you must become obedience
your very nature must be transformed into what obedience wants so you would want to dishonor me
he said and cause others not to believe that it is myself so she doesn't realize what's actually
at stake furthermore you must know he said that in order to entrust you with the mission of my will
though I did not remove from you the original sin as I did with my beloved mother I removed from
you the source of concubizance and the seed of corruption what a blessed woman she is
wow so she didn't have the struggles that the rest of us have I removed from you the source
of the concubizance and the seed of corruption because it befitted the decorum and the sanctity
of my will you see he has already explained eloquently that the graces that had to be given
to our blessed mother in order for her to be the mother of the redeemer it was because God was coming
into her womb and if we know anything I could say I know nothing about the extraordinary purity
and holiness of God we'd probably be terrified coming in touch with it that if we knew anything
about this we would somehow grasp that anything touching that infinite holiness would simply
burn up and you get examples of this in the early part of the exodus when God was trying to
teach people something of his holiness that when people rebelled like Dathan and Ibira
then fire came out from the sanctuary and just brought them up did no idea of the extraordinary
holiness of God and so Jesus explains to Louisa we had to give you these graces for the sake of
the divine will so you can see my dear friends why all of us have a long journey in the divine will
to get to that point where we actually lay down our wills before God because all of this purification
has to happen and sin and imperfections and bad habits and wrong ways of thinking and wrong influences
that have come in on our lives and everything all of that's got to be dealt with got rid of
and that we have to go through not only a purification of the senses but we've got to go through a
purification of the intellect and the memory and the will and believe me that's fire then the
divine will can reign in other words he has to prepare a fitting dwelling place for himself
so if any of you feel you're not ready to make the solemn public consecration that's perfectly
okay perfectly okay it'll come in its own time and its own way
so it was for the sake of the divine will that all these marvelous graces had to be given to Louisa
for the divine will could not take its place in a corrupted will and nature nature means body
that's why blessed mother had to be given the gift of the immaculate conception she had to
so that she would be a true tabernacle of God and that she could carry the presence of God without
being annihilation and for a little person like Louisa to be able to carry the sacredness and
wholeness of the divine will inside of her without being annihilation is a critical as well
so i want to give you Hebrews 12 14 nothing unholy or unworthy can enter the presence of God
now i want to give you revelation 21 27 where at the very end of the bible having told us
endlessly about God's wholeness and the unholyness of the human race we're told that anybody still
sinning is outside of the new Jerusalem there's no way you can get into the presence of God
everyone inside is surrendered to the divine will so Jesus says that something that is not
fitting for the divine will is a bit like having clouds before the sum of the divine will and
the knowledge about the divine will like rays would not penetrate and take deep possession of the
soul this is very very interesting because we know that many people coming into the divine will
find all of this material very difficult in the beginning and as you grow deeper and deeper in
the divine will and that you allow the Lord to purify you more and more and more suddenly this
material becomes good and then it becomes ordinary and then it becomes yeah this is right
and all the material that was so apparently difficult in the beginning it's not so difficult
after a while and so the reason why these clouds of imperfections and how do you say it involuntary
venial sins and so on they're like clouds blocking the divine rays of light from penetrating through
completely to us so that we can have possession of God and he can have possession of us now since
my will is in you Louisa Jesus was saying all heaven they need to really watch this because we
don't realize how incredibly important is the laying down of the will and the handing over the
will to God and this is why I was putting the breaks in last night speaking to people
he said since my will is in you as they were speaking all heaven the most holy virgin
all the saints and all the angels are bound to you because they're all in the divine will
the divine will is the life of each one of them so Zoni one will that means they're all bound
into the same will and if somebody does something wrong then it affects everybody
therefore he said when you hesitate even slightly doing God's will or when you reflect on whether
you shoot it here or not whoops put a big end baby side that should I or shouldn't die and this
is the this is the rationalizing that we like to do and then we can think of all kinds of reasons
why the what we wanted to do anyway was the right way when you reflect on whether you should
adhere or not heaven and earth feel shaken from their very foundations why because the divine will
is in the earth it's in everything in the earth it's in everything in the heavens the divine will
is the essence of heaven the divine will is in all creatures it's in all things maintaining everything
and he said you can shake the whole thing I don't think we realize I don't think we realize what
we're into heaven and earth feel shaken from their very foundations because that will is the life
of them all and that will which by its highest goodness wants to reign in you as it does in heaven
meaning nobody in heaven is giving opposition and nobody in heaven is saying will I or won't I or
will it be good for me or advantageous to me or not advantageous by doing this nobody in heaven
is doing that and the challenge for us is to do God's will as it is done in heaven so you go to
Revelation chapters four and five Revelation seven and what you find is that everybody is in
adoration and subjection to God oh we don't like that though what about me what about me
we don't like this giving over we agree with the theoretically of course
so what he wants is that the divine will would reign in us as it does in heaven and he says with
your hesitation and with your rationalizing it doesn't have its full dominion it doesn't have
its just honor therefore I recommend to you never again call your will to life
now that's about as strong as you can get either you hand over your will or you don't again that's
why I put the brakes in last night either you hand it over or you don't and if you hand it over
you're not taking it back I recommend never again call your will to life and if you want your Jesus
to be honored in you and my will to remain with its full dominion okay it's just this is a different
world to the world of those holy people who are loving God and serving God and spending time in
prayer and all the rest of it but their own will is safe in their own hands okay
Louisa said I was frightened in hearing of the great evil that I do by merely reflecting
on whether or not I should surrender on what Jesus wants of me even though I always end up
surrendering yeah but you see that's the business of volumes one to ten you're in a different place
now and that's why the before and after consecrating yourself to God handing over your will
the the conditions of your life are vastly different they're just vastly different this is not the
time to be thinking and rationalizing and deciding where to usually give you give in in the end you
know that's not it you give glory to God in your be it done unto me according to your word not my
will but thine be done without thinking it all through what would happen if she said man made this
never be I did not actually surrender now she has touched on the seriousness of what she's into
I felt distressed she said fearing that I might do that and my beloved Jesus having compassion on
my from my distress as I felt crushed fearing that may it never be I might not always do his will
he came back and he told me my daughter courage do not be afraid so he has to correct us because
otherwise we won't be going forward and then he has to come back and encourages it's a bit like
how you deal with the small child you know you need to direct them and if they do something
wrong you need to correct them and then if you don't give them the big hug and tell them they're
wonderful they can't really move on so he said I have told you this and I have showed you how
all of heaven is bound to that will of mine which reigns in you so that you may never surrender
to your will because the divine will and the human will are the fiercest enemies of each other
that's why I don't recommend that you do this public consecration unless the fierce enemy of the
human will is willing to let some other will dominate it and we can say oh yeah I'm willing I'm
willing I'm willing when it comes to the crunch it can be different the human will and the divine
will are the fiercest enemies of other they're the words of Jesus not Louisa and since the divine
will is stronger holier more immense it's fitting that its enemy the human will should remain under
its feet and serve as a footstool to the divine will now we agree with that theoretically it's
quite another matter to get yourself into that position in fact one who must live in my will
must not consider himself a terrestrial citizen but must regard himself as a citizen of heaven
because you're already living the life of heaven on earth so I want to give you Philippians chapter
three verse 20 and again Hebrews chapter 11 where it speaks about all these wonderful heroes of the
faith that they were too good for this world and I want to give you Sam 99 verse 5 I want to give
you Sam 110 verse 1 I want to give you Matthew 22 verses 41 to 44 and I want to give you Acts
235 so there's a lot about this in the New Testament so we're a citizen of heaven and it is with just
reason that all the blessed in heaven feel shaken because one who lives with their own will is thinking
of letting the human will enter the field and this is disorder and disorder has never entered
the celestial regions so we who are trying to live in the divine will could create havoc
you must be convinced that by living of my will your the life of your will is ended period that's
Corban handed over you walk away leave it there it no longer has any reason to exist
this is why I have told you many times that living in my will is very different I think
we're beginning to get the message those who do my will are free to give their all their will and
take it back because they live as terrestrial citizens they're not surrendered to God and so
yes they will do something good for God and they'll pray and they'll do this at the other but one who
lives in the divine will is bound to an eternal point that is the throne of God and flows together
with my will is surrounded by an impregnable fortress that means you can't get out once you put yourself
in but you could put yourself in frightful struggle that's why the challenge now is to do it when
you're ready then as though wanting to cheer me and to strengthen me in his most holy will he took
my hand in his and told me my daughter come and do your round in my will see my will is one thing
and it flows as though it but it flows as if it were divided in all created things but yes it's
not divided look at the stars and the azure heavens such deep space the sun and the moon and the plants
that's the localized heavens the sun and the moon the plants and the flowers the fruits the fields
the earth and the sea everything and everyone in each thing there is an act of my will and not
only an act but my will has remained in each thing as the preserver of my very act my will does not
want to remain alone in its act but wants the company of your act as well it's lovely it wants
your acquittal the way i like to put it is it wants your signature wants to know that you were around
and that you gave glory to god so this is a why i placed you in my will that you may keep company
with my acts and together with my will that you will want only what i want that's that's a very
important point and many of the saints have actually reached that point in their journey with god
saint the race of lisue became a doctor of the church at the age of 24 and she was quite clear
i choose what you choose for me she said it's very wonderful because it she was saying i will
what you will for me i'm not pulling up with it i'm not saying oh i have to do this or i have a
vow obedience so i must obey none of that now i choose what you choose that you will want what
i want that the stars twinkle that the sun fill the earth with light that the plants bloom that
the fields become golden that the birds horrible that the sea murmur that the fish dart in sun
you will want whatever why i want now i think the example he gave her is certainly not the example
i gave you i gave you an example of somebody just choosing in their everyday lives what god chose
for him but he said i want you to enter into my will and choose to be with me in giving the light
of the sun to the earth and letting the seas be alive and well don't they need it they need us
the seas are sick now of course they're sick because of human beings the atmosphere is sick but we can
enter into the divine will and we can say to the lord i want the air to be pure and i want the sun
to shine and i want the flowers to and i want the animals to thrive and i want everything it's
beautiful you can actually join him i think that's rather sweet my will will no longer feel alone
in the created things and will feel the company of your acts therefore go around through each
created thing and constitute yourself the act for each act of my will in other words enter in
participate join me this is the living in my will never to leave the creator alone to admire all
of his works and to give to him in return for his great acts the little acts of the creature
so this is continuous union continuous prayer i don't know how i found myself in that immense
void of light she said in order to find all those acts which come out of the will of god
so as to place in them the requital of my act of adoration praise love and thanksgiving and then
she said i found myself within myself so that's a wonderful message that we have received tonight
this will flow beautifully next week because we're going to talk about free will i think it's
fantastic so let's finish with a little prayer taken from volume 12 press to save your i want to
fuse myself in your humanity your divinity and your will i want to take your power wisdom and love to
myself so that i can pray with all your own things i want to lay at your feet the adoration and the
subjection of the whole human family i place in your heart the i love you of all i impress my
kiss upon your lips in order to seal the kiss of all generations i clasp you in my arms in order to
clasp you with the arms of everyone and i do this in order to bring you the glory of all souls and
the works of all souls past presence and future and united with your works and united with your
divine will united with our blessed mother and with all souls i plead come o supreme volition
and reign upon the earth invest all generations win and conquer all and do not delay any longer amen